[Music]
okay hi my name is Joe and today we're
making pizza blindfolded jasmine is my
coach and my eyes for today and the only
rule is if I touch it I must use it I
make pizza wise Joe you made pizza want
but you know what goes on Pizza oh
definitely pineapple oh we're in trouble
well unfortunately there's no pineapple
on the table so all right we're say
today all right we're good and
everything else probably belongs on a
pizza I imagine yes for the most part
definitely depending on what part of the
world drank right that's one way to look
at it you've eaten plenty of pizza
though yes I made plenty of pizza I feel
like I can sense the pizza are we ready
ready
[Music]
all right you ready to do this almost
almost almost okay I'm ready now
you ready I'm ready okay so the dough is
right in front of you need it need it
stretch it stretch it that's the word
we're looking for stretch the dough oh
it's like a nice cold ball dry flour no
go up forward a little bit
Oh to your left a little bit no too much
splits it - yeah perfect
now go back towards your body just a
little bit a little bit less yeah go
down down down down down
Oh but okay now towards your body a
little bit yep that's it
see if I can do this without seeing it
yes how am I on sighs it's pretty big
and you're close to splitting it in the
middle I don't want to do that
that's my plate you got a bit of a fat
chunk hanging towards you yeah no I can
fold it over a little bit here too just
a little bit but it looks fine all right
I got a crust we got the size of the
plate that looks pretty darn good
all right I feel pretty good about this
you feel pretty good about this I feel
great about this
okay let's raise your left hand and then
go forward about five six inches a
little no I forgot it double that
okay now go left more and then now stick
your index finger downwards so we avoid
things okay a little more to your left
splits the difference now go straight
down yeah all the way down yeah perfect
pick up that bowl am I in a bowl you are
in a bowl you can stop fingering that I
feel like if I move I'm going to touch
everything around it I'm pretty sure
this is pizza sauce let's hope that
isn't salsa you want to smell it pizza
sauce yeah okay I'm so sorry about your
finger it's all good that's part of
cooking that's my best tool right there
yeah all right so this is gonna go on is
there spoon perfect that was the center
feel free to go a little more right you
are now off the left crust left side of
the crust
maybe one more dollop on the right side
yeah that's perfect
you're killing it Joe sounds like
something Lucy okay I think that's
enough
sauce let's put the sauce down maybe to
your right don't touch anything okay
put the bowl down put the ball down and
then push it yeah
nice nice okay look let's okay oh I need
to do something about this lick it
wow you're so athletic
yeah that's the first time anyone's ever
said that to me next topping please all
right raise your right hand and yes
wonderful forward a lot a little less
and then go right forward down and
that's the cheese that's a lot yeah I
like a cheesy pizza yay am i all over
the center here you are a left of the
center just slightly that's a little oh
that's perfect that's wonderful I'm
senior circular motions here yeah oh you
dropped all of it all right but you'll
be able to find it it's not gone it's
gone forever and then go downwards a
little bit a little less down yeah go
left a little bit oh okay let's just
play it every way each pizza is its own
snowflake its own unique snowflake
all right next raise your hand your
right hand above the pizza uh-huh now go
forward a little bit
oh no that's a little bit can you
squeeze it in your face and smell it a
little it's sweet Oh strawberry syrup oh
my god okay
just a little bit sweet and savory is
good perfect stop oh my god Bon Appetit
beautiful it's actually very nice on
camera I will say okay let's raise your
right hand again try that a higher and
then to your right slightly to your left
just a little bit uh-huh and then stick
your middle your feet index finger and
top okay now pointed downwards bring
your finger towards your body a little
bit to your right
little more little less it's like that
crane game board let's down towards your
body a little bit down down all the way
down yeah perfect
maybe use the spoon spoon is do you have
any hangnails no we're good okay cool
wash my hands what are what is this
jalapeno you bring your fingers
I like jalapenos are fine and then to
your right a little bit uh-huh
good yes let's go for the pepperoni oh I
like that Baroni raise your right hand
and then flat over the table a little
higher towards the right uh no less to
the left again yeah and then forward a
little less split the difference
uh-huh to your right just a little bit
yeah and then now pull your finger down
and a little forward oh yeah straight
down Oh
forward a little bit squeeze okay I'm
down yeah awesome
careful does bottle over there does that
count better not count I didn't touch
anything I didn't touch anything good oh
my god wedding no you're doing great
it's very stressful this is the most
stressful pizza I've ever made
it's going on for instinct on where this
pepperoni should land yeah go right a
little more when you go back in the
other yeah it's way right a little more
right okay that's right
okay that's good right that's a good
luck I did good yes well bit okay
beautiful do you like all is I love
olives okay let's go for the olives left
hand slide over the table fat towards
your body uh-huh and then stick your
index finger out to your right a little
bit and a little less and then stick it
down oh my god this is so hard it's so
small
okay towards you just a tiny bit oh god
there's a spoon okay Oh to your right a
little more and then can you raise your
wrist just a little bit oh that's
beautiful
okay towards you
to your left now to your left a little
more yes straight down and then watch
your thumb it'll touch us spoon aha oh
yeah all right it's like diffusing a
bomb I know it
where's the pizza here so yeah we're
gonna go minimal ologist grab a lot
looks good I think we're good with just
one more ingredient all right I trust
you it's probably the most important
part of this pizza okay raise your right
hand flat over the table forward a
little more and then to your left a
little little bit more to your left
Oh less and then stick your index finger
down uh yeah go straight down that's it
hold the bowl or grab some it's really
important you have to add a lot of oh I
know exactly what these are what is it I
can feel their pineapples the best part
these are huge pineapples add some to
your right yes this is a very less heavy
pizza all right
like our and shoot everything over
perfect it's like all of the facts but I
think it's wonderful you can meet the
left side all right do we have it we
have it do we nail it we did it
the most unconfident it looks like we
murdered something really oh man I felt
really good about it was that you did
wonderful posing with the pizza looks
different angles okay so looks great you
look great Oh Shh all right what's left
to do do we bake it
let's bake it
pizzas baked jasmine yes come join us
join me you're so good time for the
reveal yes Wow good job no worry looks
amazing I did that blindfolded
that's pretty impressive we can wet the
pineapples are that that's the only
thing that looks weird on their cover
neon neon pink strawberry sauce looks
delicious
here we go let me let me set you up
we'll do a smaller make sure you get
pine nuts yeah I want to make sure you
get pineapple now make sure you get
pineapple we'll give you the triple
quadruple pineapple action there yeah
for you it's sopping wet
it's sopping wet and ready it's ready to
cheers yes it broke need a new slice my
girl
thank you that's you J it's a cheers to
blindfolded pizza cooking hmm and that's
a pizza boy you're a true chef yeah I
would do that again
that's how we should do them all in the
restaurant just blindfold the cooks tell
them go ahead and make a pizza I'd be a
show and a dinner that would be a dinner
and a show he wants an extra strawberry
sauce on yes sure why not
oh yeah yeah do it - oh yo I gotta know
what this tastes like
that's gross
yeah well I think we did an excellent
job as a team me too
I think we should open up a restaurant
blindfolded cooking
[Music]